l'entrée de la palissade plus le temps
passe moins l'objectif paraît impossible
à atteindre
les débats vont durer l'assemblée on le
sait ils vont probablement durer un peu
au sénat même dans des conditions
peut-être de nombreux moments
différentes ils vont pas le mans durée
au sénat la commission paritaire devra
se réunir oui je ne suis pas certain que
l'on tienne le délai du ducasse de
janvier prochain les délais sont
extrêmement contraint et en même temps
au delà des polémiques la nécessité du
débat est nécessaire chaque
parlementaire de pouvoir s'exprimer ce
qui est parfaitement légitime donc
laissons aussi faire le débat c'est
c'est la vie parlementaire c'est la vie
de cet hiver est comme ça faisons le
dans de très bonnes conditions mais ne
ne faut pas se donner des dates
impérative alors même que nous savons
que probablement nous ne pourrons pas
l'étudier